to a story you'll only see on eight news
now lost messages from the world war ii
era that's right a collection of
personal letters written more than 80
years ago has a local woman searching
for its rightful owner so the big
question is how did they end up here
hector mejia with a story
more than 16 million americans served
during world war ii
personal letters show jack jones second
lieutenant in the u.s army was one of
them vieira 1941 to 1947. i thought oh
my god that's got to be old and then i
started looking at the dates i'm like no
way theresa bergstrom found the letters
preserved
in an ammunition box part of the
contents she says she bought online from
a storage unit in henderson at first i
was going to throw them away but then i
saw the significance of the letters that
they were from world war ii and i
thought oh my god i got to read these as
we read these letters we came across
this one dated december 8 1941 a pivotal
time in world history yesterday about 10
30 we received news over the radio to
the effect that hawaii and the
philippines were attacked
our jaws drop it's referring to the
attack on pearl harbor that's just
history right there i mean the guy's
there he's in it we took this collection
to a world war ii historian at unlv he's
supplying munitions to the combat troops
and was organizing large convoys of
trucks still following protocol
i mean he's telling you that
he's
going somewhere he doesn't say where
they're mostly written overseas in
england france the mediterranean and
sent to an address in portland oregon
for cf chambers the writer's mother he
loved his mother very much and
kept in touch with her about everything
all parts of the war and his life
bergstrom is undertaking a mission of
her own trying to get these letters back
to the family this is history that you
know
don't just
throw it aside because i almost did i
almost threw everything out and then
when i saw
what it was i changed my mind really
quick
because i want i want the family to have
this back
hector mejia reporting live local now